c'est une journée plus que banale sur le
port du havre est les chariots cavaliers
ces grandes machines déplaçant les
conteneurs travaillent 24 heures sur 24
le but réapprovisionner les magasins de
première nécessité partout en france un
rôle essentiel pour la vie du pays en
ces temps de crise sanitaire n'a essayé
abandonné nationalement au tour de la
fédération nationale des ports et docks
de demander à ce que le gouvernement
priorise les activités essentielles et
donc les produits de première nécessité
ça c'est pas trop trop mal structuré et
donc on arrive à acheminer acheminer des
denrées de première nécessité et les
faire les faire véhiculer vers tous les
points d'approvisionnement du pays
premier port de france en volume de
marchandises à des milliers de dockers
et travailleurs portuaires viennent ici
travailler tous les jours mais depuis le
13 mars dernier leurs conditions de
travail ont dû s'adapter aux règles de
sécurité
ici pas question d'y déroger on essaie
que tout le monde soit équipé alors ça a
été compliqué parce que évidemment il ya
une rupture de stock au niveau national
donc elle a fallu bassiste mdl et je
vois dans les pharmacies qui pouvait
produire du gel hydroalcoolique donc
après c'était trouver d'autres moyens
pour des la désinfection donc nous on
avait trouvé des choses basiques comme
de l'eau et de la javel et des
réalisateurs désinfecté au début du
shift et à la fin du shift pour
justement que le poste reste le moins
contaminés possible donc après ouais
c'est le système d c'est
essayez de apprendra aussi un lien c'est
le correspondant sécurité chaque service
à un correspondant sécurité
est ce cette personne-là et impôts le
garant de la sortie de stocks au niveau
du magasin pour pour approvisionner les
gens qui sont dans le paix certes et
pour tenter de travailler en toute
sécurité les salariés se sont organisés
distribution de kits de masques
nettoyage régulier des postes de travail
face à la pénurie de gel hydroalcoolique
les salariés du port du havre ont aussi
trouvé la solution
alors au niveau du gel les camarades
dockers au niveau de son de formation de
machine qui fabrique le carrément la le
gel donc ça aujourd'hui aucun souci même
dans les cavaliers vous pas regarder ya
du matériel hi à tous au niveau des sous
quand il ya aucun problème aussi là
dessus c'est surtout un petit point le
price au niveau des masques mais
aujourd'hui on va dire ça crs assange
sachant qu'on a aussi adapté aux
démasqué tissu pour des gens qui sont
pas dans les premières approches
c'est donc une ville dans la ville qui
fourmillent jour et nuit qui contribuent
elles aussi à l'effort national bateau
train camion ce sont plusieurs tonnes de
marchandises qui quittent chaque jour le
port du havre à destination des quatre
coins du pays